- [Voiceover] So, I
have this somewhat hairy
function definition here,
and I want to see if we can graph it.
And this is a piecewise function.
It's defined as a different,
essentially different lines.
You see this right over here,
even with all the decimals
and the negative signs,
this is essentially a line.
It's defined by this line
over this interval for x,
this line over this interval of x,
and this line over this interval of x.
Well, let's see if we can graph it.
I encourage you, especially
if you have some graph paper,
to see if you can graph
this on your own first
before I work through it.
So, let's think about this first interval.
When negative 10 is
less than or equal to x,
which is less than negative two,
then our function is defined
by negative 0.125x plus 4.75.
So this is going to be a
line, a downward sloping line,
and the easiest way I can
think about graphing it is
let's just plot the endpoints
here, and then draw the line.
So, when x is equal to 10,
sorry, when x is equal to
negative 10, so we would have
negative zero, actually
let me write it this way.
Let me do it over here where I do the,
so we're going to have negative 0.125
times negative 10 plus 4.75.
That is going to be equal to, let's see,
the negative times a
negative is a positive,
and then 10 times this is
going to be 1.25 plus 4.75.
That is going to be equal to six.
So, we're going to have the
point negative 10 comma six.
And that point, and it
includes, so x is defined there,
it's less than or equal to,
and then we go all the
way to negative two.
So, when x is equal to negative
two, we have negative 0.125
times negative two plus 4.75 is equal to,
see negative times negative is positive,
two times this is going to be point,
is going to be positive 0.25 plus 4.75.
It's going to be equal to positive five.
Now, we might be tempted,
we might be tempted,
to just circle in this dot over here,
but remember, this interval
does not include negative two.
It's up to and including,
it's up to negative two,
not including.
So, I'm gonna put a
little open circle there,
and then I'm gonna draw the line.
And then I'm gonna draw the line.
I am going to draw my best
attempt, my best attempt,
at the line.
Now, let's do the next interval.
The next interval, this one's
a lot more straightforward.
We started x equals negative
two, when x equals negative two
negative two plus seven is,
negative two plus seven is five.
So, negative two, so
negative two comma five,
so it actually includes
that point right over there.
So we're actually able to fill it in,
and then when x is negative one,
negative one plus seven is
going to be positive six.
Positive six, but we're not
including x equals negative one
up to and including, so it's
going to be right over here.
When x is negative one,
we are approaching,
or as x approaches negative
one, we're approaching
negative one plus seven is six.
So, that's that interval right over there.
And now let's look at this last interval.
This last interval,
when x is negative one,
you're going to have,
well, this is just going
to be positive 12 over 11
'cause we're multiplying
it by negative one,
plus 54 over 11 which
is equal to 66 over 11
which is equal to positive six.
So, we're able to fill
in that right over there,
and then when x is equal to 10,
you have negative 120 over 11.
I just multiplied this times 10,
12 times 10 is 120, and
we have the negative,
plus 54 over 11.
So this is the same thing.
This is going to be, what is this?
This is negative 66
over 11, is that right?
Let's see, if you, yeah,
that is negative 66 over 11,
which is equal to negative six.
So when x is equal to 10,
our function is equal to negative six.
And so this one actually
doesn't have any jumps in it.
It could've, but we see,
so there we have it.
We have graphed this function
that has been defined
in a piecewise way.